mais il arrive aussi très
merveilleusement que la littérature
influence profondément ses lecteurs
ainsi l'on dit que si monsieur madame
johnny hallyday se sont réconciliés
c'est grâce à gilbert cesbron voici
l'explication cesbron a publié un roman
c'est mozart qu'on assassine dans lequel
il traite du douloureux problème des
enfants de parents divorcés de ces
mozart assassiné par la désunion de
leurs parents or il paraîtrait que
sylvie aurait lui c'est mozart qu'on
assassine et très émue très touché ses
rangs votre son coeur son enfant et se
serait écrié
mais c'est david qu'on assassine et
c'est ainsi qu'elle aurait fait la paix
avec johnny on dit de même que si jo
bouillon a regagné les milandes où
l'attendait joséphine bancaire et ses 13
enfants c'est aussi après avoir lu c'est
mozart qu'on assassine
mais je ne suis pas du tout d'accord
avec la thèse de monsieur cesbron un
psychologue anglais
monsieur victor geurts elle a étudié ce
qu'étaient les parents de 400 hommes et
femmes illustres des écrivains des
hommes politiques des musiciens des
compositeurs des peintres et il a
constaté que 80 à 90 % des parents de
ces génies des pères et mères de ces
génies et bien étaient des gens peu
recommandables et faillit des ratés des
alcooliques des fous
le divorce est un moindre mal donc bien
loin d'assassiner mozart il semble qu'au
contraire un climat familial où le lui
donne le la et toujours d'après monsieur
recel il semble que qu'en reprenant la
vie commune johnny et sylvie hallyday
est quelque peu diminué leurs chances de
faire de david hallyday à mozart si tant
est qu'il en ait qu il a envie